This video will primarily be addressing the
first half of the Mandalorian season 3 and
I’ll also touch on episode 5.
So far, this season feels hollow to me for
a multitude of different reasons and the first
one I want to go into is the overall arc that
Mando has, or lack of one in season 3.
Through seasons 1 and 2 we go from a ruthless
bounty hunter who doesn’t ask questions,
to a more sympathetic father figure who cares
for this youngling he has bonded to.
In this time, you could kind of excuse some
of the side quests for being fillery because
at the bare minimum, Grogu’s and Mando’s
time together filled your interest.
It gave Mando a solid arc and it imbued him
with an immense purpose because he had an
important objective to achieve.
Any obstacle along the way was also pretty
fun because you had a lot of investment within
this duo in getting to their end goal.
Like when Grogu gets kidnapped you immediately
feel that gut punch and the drive to get him
back is exciting.
On top of the endpoint for this objective
being inherently interesting because we get
to meet a Jedi, along with there being a mystery
as to who it will be.
So from a plot basis and a character basis,
seasons 1 and 2 were able to keep you captivated.
In season 3, there hasn’t been a strong
and engaging throughline to hook you as a
viewer.
Especially for the first 4 episodes where
the plot meanders a lot with not much to look
forward to.
Mando doesn’t really have any semblance
of an arc so far and his only objective was
to bathe in the waters of Mandalore.
Which in turn, this goal didn’t really give
him much to work with as a character since
he’s just fulfilling some arbitrary objective
to redeem himself.
Once he achieves this goal, the show doesn’t
establish another objective for Mando.
However, episode 5 does a good job at partially
rectifying this issue.
Giving Mando the task of helping Nevarro was
pretty good and I’m interested in seeing
how this development evolves later on.
Even though it feels like the writers are
starting to set a precedence in that they
aren’t interested in giving Mando much character
development.
It seems like he’s hit a point where he’s
stayed the same since the end of season 2.
I wish they would explore him learning how
to use the dark saber more because that’s
by far the coolest aspect the show has set
up, but yet, it feels largely neglected.
The creators seem to be shifting their focus
towards Bo Katan which is fine to a degree,
but this in turn leaves Mando out to dry.
Now you may be thinking that Mando doesn’t
need much deep character work which is partially
true.
However, what made the earlier seasons so
compelling was the bond between Mando and
Grogu and the amount of heart that came with
that.
So since that arc has been finished, there
is a big void at the core of The Mandalorian
that needs to be filled, and that hasn’t
in my opinion.
I think they tried to refill that void by
bringing back Grogu, but it feels very forced
and it’s as if Disney panicked and brought
him back as soon as possible.
It seems like they didn’t really understand
what made him so special within the story
and now he’s mostly here to be cute and
play paintball.
To me, It would make the most sense that the
original plan for the show was to have Grogu
exit permanently after season 2, or at worst
coming back after season 3.
Because by bringing him back so soon, it diminishes
that strong farewell.
Which was by far the highest point in the
show and I don’t know if they’ll ever
be able to get to that level of quality again.
To make things even worse, they included Grogu’s
return in The Book of Bobba Fett which was
just a wild decision.
Having such a huge development for Mando not
in his own show is baffling to me.
Especially since those two episodes of The
Mandalorian within The Book of Boba Fett were
far meatier than what we’ve gotten in most
of season 3 so far.
So I feel bad for the casual viewers who were
confused when Grogu was back because they
didn’t even explain it in the recap.
But yeah, Grogu’s place in the show feels
artificial, and seems like he’s just there
because Disney didn’t want to take a hit
in merchandise sales.
I can’t shake the feeling that the original
plan for season 3 was a Bo Katan and Mando
arc without Grogu.
I think it would have been much better if
they solely paired these two characters together
because what’s happening to Bo right now
is kind of interesting.
Albeit it’s pretty underdeveloped so far
considering how short the episodes have been.
The writers really need to write more dialogue
scenes and commit to actual character development
because the little screen time we’ve had
is mostly reserved for action.
Which is fun, but you can only get so far
with spectacle.
On top of also spending a ton of time exploring
characters like Dr. Pershing.
The fact that he has gotten significantly
more character work in comparison to our main
hero is insane from a writing perspective.
The episodes are essentially averaging 30ish
minutes and with an additional 10 minutes
of time focusing on characters an episode,
it would feel a lot better.
That’s what the standard should be for these
kinds of shows especially since there are
only eight episodes.This is about the same
amount of content in the past, but since we
are lacking certain elements like solid objectives
and character work, along with other things
I’ll bring up later in the video, it feels
like we’re receiving less value from each
episode.
Because of this lack of care being put into
the script lengths, I’m feeling more and
more detached from Mando and it feels like
he’s fading away.
I also hate how they are kind of knocking
down his character to have Bo repeatedly save
him like in episode 2.
Him blindly walking into an aquifer while
also taking off his jetpack was really silly
to me.
I think there can definitely be a better execution
for their pairing in which you’d treat them
more as equals.
Or at the very least, have Mando actively
progress to a point where he matches Bo’s
level.
Along with giving him a complimentary arc
so that he’s not aimlessly following her
around.
There may just be eight episodes, but this
is something that is necessary for storytelling.
Another remedy would be to reduce Grogu’s
time in the show and allocate that time to
other characters.
A lot of his moments are starting to feel
more like fan service instead of progressing
any form of relationship or the story.
An example being the paintball scene.
Unless if they are developing Grogu into becoming
a Mandalorian or something, which would just
be ridiculous, then him training here is not
necessary for the plot.
Cutting out Grogu in general isn’t currently
attainable since he’s already back, but
they really need some more scenes between
Mando and Bo.
And dialogue that isn’t solely driven by
lore like in episode 2.
Because it felt like Bo was a tour guide in
that episode.
Also by leaving Grogu out of the season, it
shakes up the status quo of the show and it
forces the writers to get creative, and not
rely on Grogu’s cuteness.
And the thing is that the setting for most
of the season is within this group of Mandalorians
so the recipe is already shaken up and the
writers have to utilize that fact more.
I’d much rather have scenes of the Mandalorians
telling stories and talking to each other,
rather than Grogu having more PTSD flashbacks.
Or hell, even establishing more Mandalorian
characters because it’s a pretty sparse
roster right now.
All we have is the armorer and this big dude
and that’s it.
If we had a few other characters to look to
within the ranks of the Mandalorians, this
group would be much more interesting and you
could spawn more dialogue scenes naturally
thus growing your characters.
I feel like a golden opportunity to add in
a scene with a bit of character development
would have been during the dinner by the fire
in episode 4.
They could have easily included some dialogue
before they started eating and instead, the
writers end it quickly by passing out food
and everyone leaves.
The thing that stings even more is that this
episode is only 26 minutes long and if you
cut out the Grogu flashback which felt redundant,
given that we learned about that in season
2 and by seeing all of it, it doesn’t add
much to the story, the episode would have
been 22 minutes long.
So it feels like Jon Favreau, whose the sole
writer of season 3 so far, is not putting
enough time and care into the scripts.
And he’s been the primary writer for both
The Mandalorian and The Book of Boba Fett,
so I’m starting to think that he’s the
one that’s probably at fault.
If there’s anyone to blame for the botchery
of The Book of Boba Fett, it would be Jon
Favearu because those scripts were dogshit.
I’m sorry but they were.
The Mandalorian season 3 is starting to show
its cracks and the lack of expansion overall
and evolution of Mando is hindering the show.
Because the fact that we are 5 episodes in
and we had a beginning episode that was absolutely
pointless given that Mando just gets some
other random droid instead of the one he wanted
on Nevarro, episode 3 primarily following
characters who aren’t relevant to the current
plot, and episode 4 which is 22 minutes without
the flashback is starting to show some worrying
signs for the writing.
Episode 5 is giving me some hope, but I’m
afraid that this sudden burst of productivity
in the plot will be met with 2 episodes where
barely anything happens.
When other shows like The Last of Us have
more character and plot development in a single
episode than half of your season then you
need to provide more content.
Not to mention the fact that there’s been
a 3-year time gap between seasons 2 and 3.
It’s crazy to me that season 2 was back
in 2020.
We’re getting old man.
So the amount of content and quality that
we are getting feels rough.
I know we’ve gotten lots of side quest episodes
in the past, but at the very least they were
motivated by a general objective.
And there was even an overarching villain
presence within the first two seasons.
Moff Gideon was a menacing character who was
always operating in the background to apply
pressure to our characters.
And the stormtroopers that Mando occasionally
ran into, felt like an extension of Moff Gideon’s
power.
In season 3, that villain threat is Gorian
Shard and it’s obviously a major step down,
but he is a short-term villain.
The biggest issue with Gorian is that his
presence at this point in the show relies
on a major contrivance.
Firstly, him having a form of peace with Nevarro
is kind of weird because pirates aren’t
known for making peace.
They do whatever they want and raid whatever
they want.
Then secondly, the fact that Greef Karga has
no defenses on Nevarro and has the audacity
to say this: “Sure you want to let him go?
He’ll let it be known that Nevarro is respectable
and not to be trifled with.”
Like what?
You literally just gunned down a bunch of
pirates which will undoubtedly antagonize
their leader.
And what the hell is stopping him from raiding
Nevarro now?
There are zero defenses and Greef Karga I
guess just hopes that Gorian won’t attack
his city because nothing is stopping him.
It’s also funny how Greef only sends out
a notice for help until they get attacked
and doesn’t bother with any safety precautions
for if Gorian does attack.
It’s just a very stupid scenario and is
only this way so that Mando can get the help
of the Mandalorians to save the day.
So this brief villain was not great, and I
feel like people are loving this so much right
now because we are finally getting some form
of progression.
Despite this being the fifth episode in the
season and there are only 3 left now.
Hopefully, Jon Favreau will start applying
some pressure towards our heroes since they
finally announced that Moff Gideon escaped.
At this point, if any character doesn’t
die on-screen in Star Wars they are guaranteed
to come back, or even if they do die then
they have a high chance of coming back too.
But hopefully, Moff’s return will spawn
a more consistent throughline of conflict
that will make future obstacles more engaging.
If I had to guess, they’ll probably reserve
his appearance for a finale cliffhanger and
will slow down the pace for the next couple
of episodes.
I do hope I’m wrong though.
Overall, most of the season has a lack of
purpose and objective, development for our
main character feels non-existent, the villain
presence is lacking, and the return of Grogu
is cheap and detracts from the story at this
point.
I know there are still 3 episodes left and
the show can turn around so I’m reserving
my final judgment for an overall review when
the season ends.
As a side note, I’m on the fence about continuing
the Baby Yoda But with Subtitles series.
I feel like I should since they are really
popular, but it feels weird because I haven’t
made those videos in a while, so we’ll see.
Regardless though, thank you for watching,
and let me know in the comments what you think
about The Mandalorian season 3 so far.